wanna know what's heating up in theaters  this weekend convention in the  provocative thriller get out  directed by Jordan Peele a young black  man learns a disturbing truth wait wait  wait that's I've decided to become a  music lucious crazy talk  a Tibetan Mastiffs leave home to fulfill  his dream of being a rock star in rock  dog you are totally on fire  you blow up my room you my room I'm  gonna fight you I'm sorry what Ice Cube  and Charlie Day play teachers about to  meet in the parking lot after school in  fist fight you got it I don't think  you've got this see what's hot in  theatres with this week's anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]